à nous d aller ouvre la bouche
tiens c'est nouveau ça se mange pas
est-ce que c'est ok excusez-moi danger
en vue laisser faire les gros non mais
c'est quoi cet ol siddig où elle est là
pour empêcher riley de s'empoisonner
physiquement et socialement la couleur
m'inspire pas c'est pas top au niveau de
la forme attendez j'ai juste de nous
sauver la vie riley fini ton assiette où
tu seras privé de dessert
pourquoi pas de désert en battant il est
sérieux lui ouais la colère il est très
à cheval sur la justice et
l'impartialité
ouais alors c'est comme ça que tu prends
moustache pas de dessert donc et battu
en plus on va te finir dans les 6 mais
c'est surtout toi qui vas tu as juste
regarde le savions
l'avion on à l'avion mais view 3 e